foreign
age of less than one year old a violent
civil war broke out in my home country
of the Democratic Republic of Congo
as a result my family was forced to flee
and as luck could have it we found
safety in kangwa refugee camp located in
Western Uganda where I grew up from and
have learned to call home for the past
24 years
every morning my two parents would wake
up at 5 am and leave for the fields
where they want to cultivate our small
garden to plant Maize and beans to feed
the family
and every evening when they came back
home they would end the night in the
same way usually they would gather me
and my siblings and would give us a pep
talk on how much the desire to us go to
school and be educated
surprisingly none of my parents actually
had gone to school but to them education
meant securing a well-paying job at some
point in the future and with this we had
afford three meals a day we perhaps
could build a nice looking house for our
family or even decide to take our family
from the refugee camp to the city and so
when I started going to school I took
this at heart and I took School serious
even that was just a little kid I
managed to work myself out of bed take
our three goals to Grace and be back on
time to dress up and go to school
can be overcrowded I was one of the
nearly 200 students who sat in a single
classroom as I tried to focus and learn
but besides the problem of overcrowded
classrooms we also had an issue by most
of our learning was characterized by
Road memorization on a typical day we
showed up in a classroom copped down
notes that teachers gave us and we
expected to go back home cram this in
preparation for exams and if I can be
honest with you I did not enjoy this
and even Among Us ourselves and even
though as a serious students most of the
time schools seem to be very boring
however as I was growing up and as I
took on the routine of going to school
in the morning and then coming back to
my family in the evening there seemed to
be one thing and one thing only that
through him held my attention and that
was the idea of playing games and I most
loved playing the game of football now
I'll start off by addressing the biggest
elephant in the room I know most of you
love American football but actually
that's not the game I'm talking about
I'm five foot three and given my size I
truly can't play American football so
I'm actually talking about football what
we used our feet and that's soccer
I also loved playing the cards of Spades
and most of the time after school I
would come to my house and I'll be
holding a deck of cards and every time
my parents saw me suffering these cards
they'll be paranoid thinking I'd started
gambling
but I wasn't and perhaps because I even
didn't have money to do so
no wonder while in high school in 2016
the idea of gamification
became the best solution I thought about
I could use to be able to address the
problem in the refugee camp and since
then I've been on a quest to make
education more accessible and more fun
and engaging for children within kangar
FG Camp through the use of both games
and if you don't mind I'm going to share
with you how it all happened
one year before in 2015 I was lucky and
got an opportunity to go and study at
Africa Leadership Academy located in
Johannesburg South Africa and here I was
introduced to the idea of
Entrepreneurship for the first time and
my amazing teachers taught me that
entrepreneurs were simply problem
solvers and I immediately knew that I
wanted to work on an educational problem
the first idea I thought I could build a
primary school more children would
access learning spaces teachers would
not have the problem of overcrowded
classrooms but the problem was I was 19
years old didn't have the money didn't
have the skills of what it took to build
a primary school the second idea I
thought I could advocate for a
well-equipped library with this we would
have enough textbooks in the library and
children would have enough reading
materials they would do it at school in
performing international exams however I
had one issue with the library you see
food can be discussed in the refugee
camp and several times when I showed up
at school I personally remembered every
time I entered in the library all I
could think about was full
more than anything I needed the solution
that was cheap a solution that was
scalable and something that would be
very exciting to the children
something that someone would help these
children forget about their hunger and
then engage with running but also
something that would help teachers have
control on overcrowded classrooms but
most importantly help children engage
with the algebra with the science they
were learning and have fun every single
day they came to school
and so even though I had never taken
drawing classes I picked up a pencil and
got some courage to start making
sketches of what would be my first board
game I also generated a number of
trivial questions and then called up my
former primary school teacher in FG camp
and they asked if I could visit my
primary school once again
it was generous and he said yes
when I showed up at my former Primary
School the kids were excited
and most of them jumped out of their
seats when I told them what I held in my
hands was a board game
surprisingly none of them actually knew
even how the game was played but heading
towards the board game they were
thrilled
working with the teachers on the school
administration they gave me about one
hour to test out the game for the next
couple weeks and the game was a huge
success so much so that the next morning
my mom walked me out of bed telling me
that there was a group of children
wearing my school uniform looking for me
I was still confused because it was
about 6 a.m in the morning
but I woke up out of my bed still in my
address actually and then opened the
door there was about six children and
when I looked at them there were about
two faces that I could recognize there
was gems and Patrick two of the children
I had worked with the previous day
and with Innocent faces that the prayer
have ever seen they were like could you
come and join us at school and then we
played the game before school starts
and looking at their faces there was no
way I was going to say no I said I'll
dress up and meet you over by school and
this group of amazing children became my
early testers who'd play the game in the
morning and then in the afternoon as
they waited for their afternoon shift
and today the game has evolved into what
my team and I at my home stars and and
profit we are running in Uganda have
called the five stars educational board
game and here's how the five stars
education board works
at the beginning a classroom divides
itself into groups of five children and
these children begin interacting with
one another on questions and content
we've developed in partnership with a
group of 16 teachers
all this content is a reflection of the
actual content covered in the Ugandan
educational curriculum of mathematics
English science and social studies and
as they interact they get to earn points
for every trivia question they get right
and they use these points to advance
around the star-shaped board with the
goal of being the first one to enter the
middle and take on the big yellow star
which usually gets children very excited
my team and I also have worked together
to incorporate game mechanics such as
chance and Jeopardy where children
actually can earn extra points when they
collaborate and help each other on
difficult trivia questions this has been
intended to make sure that children are
actually running the components of
communication and working together in
teams but also it makes learning become
more child centered and actually
teachers can focus on groups of children
that are struggling most a model that we
are finding to be very helpful in
communities such as refugee camp where
most of the time we don't have enough
teachers and there's one particular
reason as to why my team and I decided
to call the game the five stars and it's
simply the conviction that no matter
where you're from and the current
existing circumstances we can all Reach
for the Stars
and like now the grass Tyson would put
it not only do we live Among the Stars
the Stars themselves live within us and
that includes children from refugee
camps
and the students also start playing the
game we encourage them not to use their
action names but actually to take on the
characters of the five brightest stars
in the galaxy and that cannot pass raijo
octurus Vega and then serious and also
when we hand them the board game we
remind them that they already stars who
are interacting with one another to help
each other just shine a little bit
brighter and perhaps our biggest impact
was their eyes in 2020 and 2021 like
most of you remember these are the tiers
when covid-19 pandemic decided to visit
us and during this time
classes in refugee camp closed and
children were sent home with no way of
accessing learning resources
my team and I took on the challenge to
make learning happen within homes and we
produced about 1000 game packages that
we gave to teachers and Community
leaders and with this we're able to help
about 5 000 children to access Home
Learning in the most fun and engaging
way through the use of board games today
we are working with five schools in
kangware FG cam where we've actually
been able to work with School
administration to make the five-stars
part of the learning schedules in the
morning children spend the morning time
learning the normal classes they're
supposed to take in the curriculum and
then spend about one hour in the
afternoon to put what they've learned in
the morning into practice
Beyond being a game that is helping
children Master the curriculum content
and do it in the National exam
my team and I are committed to continue
building the five stars into a Learning
Resource that will continue to put a
smile on these children faces every
single day they come to class and the
game that can continue to inspire them
into what is possible for them in the
future and also we are committed to
continue building this game into a game
that we shall be able to make available
to other children in another refugee
camps across Uganda and other countries
across the African continent
in the past one year about 100 million
people across the world have been
displaced and many of these are as a
result of a civil war
from kangora refugee camp in Western
Uganda
to New York City and standing in front
of via today and engaging with you is a
big big privilege
and the only reason I'm able to do so
and stand in front of you is because
I've been given an opportunity to go to
school
and while both games such as the five
stars will not be able to solve some of
the world's complex problems of the 21st
Century like Refugee crisis and
displacement
I strongly believe that you and I that
are here today
that happened to be a little bit
privilege bear the responsibility to
continue building platforms and systems
that will help Refugee children imagine
a better future for themselves their
families and their communities
thank you
[Applause]